[Music]
[Applause]
i'm laura ingraham and this is our
ingram angles special Chicago townhall a
city in crisis
I got Ukraine Gaede and impeachment
drama consuming the airwaves it is easy
to forget the crisis unfolding on
America's streets and the problems being
ignored as we retreat in our political
corners well we were here in Chicago a
year ago and at that time we promised
the people in these communities and our
audience in general that would be back
and we wouldn't let these issues go and
tonight we're here to fulfill that
promise we return to assess how life has
changed or not for these violence
plagued neighborhoods and whether the
relationship between the communities and
law enforcement was it whether it's
improved or worsened the city is still
being brutalized by gang violence and
bloodshed and what are the political
leaders doing about it last year
Democrat Rahm Emanuel was finishing up
his final year as mayor and now in her
first year in office Mayor Lori
Lightfoot is facing a number of serious
challenges a looming teacher strike an
unacceptable level of gang and drug
violence and a city running out of
patience we'll explore all of it with
our live audience and expert panels but
I want you to understand what's
happening in the area we are
broadcasting from tonight we're here at
new beginnings Church and it's situated
in one of the most dangerous
neighborhoods on Chicago's South Side
now do you see the red circles on that
map well those are the homicides that
have occurred just this year alone and
children are too often the victims of
the violence here in Chicago as our own
Raymond Arroyo found on the south side
of town
we're a few miles from tonight's Town
Hall in Harvey now the violence here is
intense and to give you a sense of just
how intense the violence is in the city
of Chicago there have been 300 homicides
plus just this year over 1,600 shootings
and to bring it home for people in this
community the house behind me belongs to
Kent Vanya black Ville she's 12 years
old
earlier this week Ken Vania was making
plans for her birthday party
her family was watching the Bears game
went around 9 o'clock at night a group
of men approached the house and bullets
started flying
her family hit the deck ken Vania didn't
get up a bullet pierced the front window
and struck her in the back of the head
she died on her birthday
members of this community are still
shaken as soon as we heard it my
daughter was in the back of the house
and she got down to her to get down
mm-hmm that came out after they were out
and they
crying and stuff and screaming and
holler and it was so scary
that could happen to us you know just
random shooting everyone's pretty much
scared kids around don't I'm hearing
they're not sleeping well this is bad we
shouldn't have to actually see this
sense to his type of violence ever
pretty much all we can do is just pray I
have any hobby all my life and it's just
not like it used to be bad you find you
bring the kids in earlier now yeah oh
yeah
and they say right here nowhere else who
do you blame for this police presence
put it like that you know I'm saying we
riding around seeing what's going on in
the community even get out meet the
people it's affecting everyone at their
core here it's not a single thing of
guns you know gun rights or whatever
it's not a single thing of just that
it's it's it's a it's a gamut of things
a lot of things that come into this pot
I've been here for over 50 some years I
raised my kids here I am scared so far
this year homicides are tracking at a
slower pace than they were in 2018 but
they're still near the top for an
American city last year exceeding the
nut murder rates of both New York and LA
but for the people in these at-risk
communities the statistics they don't
mean all that much they're suffering
from unacceptable levels of routine
violence joining me now is Tony Robinson
former Chicago police officer in the
Violent Crimes Division former homicide
detective Joseph Mosely and a former
homicide detective and 30-year veteran
of the Chicago Police Department and
Anthony Williams pastor and activist
here in Chicago Tony I want to start
with you I mean it is hard to watch that
story the facts the promise of a young
girl cut short needlessly she's one
though of hundreds upon hundreds upon
hundreds of african-american youth who
get caught up in this type of violence
people watching tonight want to know
what do we do how
stop this well first of all we cannot
police our way out of this this has to
come from the community and being a
homicide detective it hurts me just as
much when I can't solve that crime when
I cannot get members of the community
who knows and I understand it because
they have to live there they don't want
to talk to the police
we need back our programs that we used
to have on the police department like
officer friendly the Explorer scouts
take the youth give them something to do
we have to really be involved with our
community and our youth and when I
worked at in 29 years everybody that
knew me knew I was a good cop and I
worked my butt off and I continued to
volunteer go to the academy talk to our
young recruits policing is a state of
mind not a state of being you can't just
put someone off the street and say
you're the police they complain about
training you know something do what you
were trained to do and everybody wants
to yell about all we need more training
no do what you were trained to do treat
people with empathy be fair and
understand that just because someone
lives in a project or a torn down
neighborhood they don't have that
mentality and it's just a very few
people that's in our community that
raises all this confusion we're gonna
get back to your son who is now a new
police officer god bless me in Chicago
if you didn't even know he was applying
for the Academy
Anthony I want to go to you because
you're an activist you have been engaged
on this issue here as a faith leader as
a community activist for years and years
people say well it's getting better be
patient it's gonna be okay it's getting
better it's trending better do you feel
that and do you understand what Tony
says but it's not this is not a policing
problem it's a community problem I lost
a son to violence February 21st 2018
near my wheels violence is the number
one problem of the 21st century thank
you what we did our response was to talk
with our state representatives Hernandez
Ford and Lily
we got a resolution passed violence the
Health crest crises the next step is we
are preparing to walk the Spree Ville on
October the 14th and the goal is is to
pass comprehensive legislation on
violence as a health crises and a
disease the system of violence is
overwhelming we all as citizens must
deal with this allocated this divided
this issue of violence is everyone's
fight history shows us in America when
you want to come at and injustice than
our evil legislation now we can't
legislate ourselves out of this a police
ourself like this but we need civility
right now civility is important violence
ain't cool civility is is powerful this
is a human health crises no one is safe
no matter where you live so we are
working towards comprehensive
legislation involving one comprehensive
reservation we'll be under health care
the CDC is saying advises the disease
but it's not a contagion we don't need
vaccines but we need comprehensive
legislation same things with like
cigarettes you know it's almost
unimaginable got a bar but you can't
smoke at a bar the more why because of
the law is the law that moves the needle
when dr. King and others got together we
need an endgame we're dealing with the
demon of segregation legislation so this
is just
one of many memphis i've worked towards
solution we know about the problem but
we came along and what our legislators
we are about to have a game-changer
that's going to deal with the issue of
violence like never before
joseph the police trust distrust level
community to police gallup poll showing
this in chicago it's not great it's not
great most people polled and the
community say they either know someone
or or they themselves have had a bad
interaction with police how do you as a
former police officer feel when you hear
that because as we heard from tony this
is a this is a commitment to be a police
officer in today's day and age being
outgunned and oftentimes understaffed
you're dealing with a difficult hurdle
to clear yet the community needs you
well I think the problem there is that
we miss identify what the real problems
are as my learning colleague said you
cannot legislate your way out of this
you can't delegate your way out of it
however we have to take a more holistic
approach understand that this is a
mental health crisis understand that
we're looking at another group of
second-generation crack babies looking
at learning disorders so we have to look
at this from a holistic approach and say
well what else do we do and understand
that a lot of police officers have a big
misunderstanding of what their job is
we are social workers for all intensive
purposes for all the rhetoric that you
hear we don't get out the car with the
gun out you're supposed to get out there
to help people plain and simple
serve and protect not but not to protect
you serve and I think that gets the
message gets convoluted the other
problem is that we have to have a
paradigm shift within the police
department it has to have another
another face that says listen
everybody's not your enemy ABC News
reporting last week dangerous week
leaves Chicago police officers besieged
by violence and loss a veteran officer
with the department's
of apprehension Union was shot
critically wounded on West Englewood
early Saturday morning the officer was
serving a warrant to take into custody a
suspect accused of shooting a woman
while riding a bike in the Fulton River
District hours earlier to other Chicago
police officers were injured after being
dragged by a fleeing vehicle outside a
White Castle near the city's Bronzeville
neighborhood if his female partner was
hospitalized in serious condition
with two collapsed lungs and fractured
ribs I want to return now to the current
leader of the city Mary mayor excuse me
Lori Lightfoot now we invited her to be
part of this townhall we would have
loved to have had her here
City Hall is just a few miles from here
I know she's very busy but she declined
our invitation that's okay
but especially with the impending
teacher strike there's a lot going on I
do hope that she joins us on the show
another time whether back in Washington
she's the door is open she has an open
invitation yesterday mayor Lightfoot did
take time out of her schedule though to
assail u.s. immigration officials ice
has begun a major effort here to remove
violent criminal illegal aliens from the
streets also adding to some of the
problems here the mayor rather than
welcoming those efforts chose to defend
her city sanctuary policies that hinder
federal law enforcement we are not going
to tolerate letting ice terrorize our
immigrant and refugee communities we
will never ever succumb to the racist
xenophobic rhetoric of ice we will
continue to ban ice from having access
to any CPD databases we will not allow
any CPD officer to cooperate with
anything related to ice in its
immigration raids Tony so the police
officers I've talked to say that makes
our lives harder because now ice has to
go into the communities to look for
these criminals these aren't like
mothers and fathers working in
restaurants these are criminal aliens
who are in the communities in gangs
pushing Florencia 13 all these other
gang Latin Kings in these neighborhoods
and now ice has to go there if they
can't arrest
the court and outside the courtrooms
your thoughts on that how does that
affect the job of police let me be
perfectly clear for anybody in this
audience I'm a black man first I'm a
police officer second I was a victim of
police brutality that's why I joined the
police department then I had to sue the
police department to get on because I
was discriminated against so all my
career has been upholding the law and if
someone is breaking the law I wouldn't
care who they are if they're illegal if
they are legal I'm going to assist any
of the other agencies that come in here
Joseph doesn't it just makes sense I
mean these are criminal illegal aliens
who are running drugs narcotics rings
gangs inside the city and the mayor is
saying no we will not cooperate with
federal authorities here I think for me
the biggest problem is that people weave
all of us in this room use this term
common sense well common sense are so
common there wouldn't be no need for
this so I'll leave with that Joseph
thank you so much Tony and Anthony I'm
gonna see you back here later on the
show when we take questions from our
great audience tonight